make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so i was supposed to record this
earlier but i got sidetracked watching
the megalodon shark movie with jason
statham
i love that movie that movie is amazing
so we are picking up with the the batman
one shot and i want to test the waters
here
with the exception of like shazam and
green lantern to a degree because it's
referenced not all the one shots are
important but they are
optional they're just kind of here for
us to cover right now by the time this
video goes live
i will already be out of town for uh
valentine's day so i won't really know
whether or not you guys care about these
tie-ins until i get back
from from valentine's day weekend myself
and mariah are going out to get some
food and we're going to go hang out at
great wolf lodge in cincinnati we're
gonna have an amazing time so
uh this picks up kind of with batman
racing off to gotham
to do his own thing and the fact is he's
actually kind of been here for a little
while he's been here for a few days
and initially he meets up with
commissioner gordon now for those of you
guys who are going to be reading
dc comics or who choose to jump into dc
comics uh because of this video or any
of the other dark side war videos that
i've done
this took place during a branding
initiative called dcu
where there really was no continuity it
wasn't like you read batman comics you
read dark side war you read superman and
it all kind of fits into a time frame so
like you read one comic and then another
and then another instead it was just
kind of read whatever you want and so
the result is that if you go and you
read the actual batman solo series
at the time commissioner gordon's batman
but when you read this commissioner
gordon is just
commissioner gordon it was really
frustrating for a lot of us who were
continuity hounds it was really sort of
driving us insane but for the average
person i think it was moderately
successful
all in all they ended up canceling it
because i think most everybody hated it
but
the important thing here is that
commissioner gordon is getting kind of
pissy and the reason why
is because what batman's been doing in
the city of gotham
is he's basically just been leading to a
series of events whereby
criminals who were handed over to the
police department have to be released
and the reason why is because of what we
talked about in the dark side war video
where batman is basically processing
pre-crime right which is to say batman
is looking at what people's intentions
are
using the mobius chair and then
essentially snatching them up and
handing them over to the cops before
they actually do anything the reality is
that the justice system cannot arrest
you for something that it thinks you
might do
if there's no tangible evidence to link
you to that particular action right so i
mean you could have
all kinds of stuff in your car and
there's no real way for them to link you
to the crime now there are laws that
kind of deal with that for example like
if you're in possession of any kind of
drug paraphernalia and you've got it
wrapped up so say for example you have
like a pound of weed and then you've got
it packaged in like
one ounce baggies just for yourself they
can arrest you for possession with
intent to distribute right because you
could
potentially distribute it it's kind of a
nonsense law and there's no reason we
should be illegal in the first place but
that's just kind of the nature of how
some of those laws work but for batman's
case
he's handing people over who he's used
the mobius chair to determine are going
to be doing things like
robbing people uh murdering other people
things like that but because the nature
of laws is that they're designed to be
reactionary which is to say
we stop you or we we arrest you after
you've done a thing
as opposed to uh being something that
happens before you do a thing
there's nothing that the justice
department can really do right there's
nothing that like you know
that the police can actually do here so
they just got to let all these guys go
and it's kind of irritating uh
commissioner gordon to a degree but more
so than that is batman
because ever since batman got on the
mobius chair
he's become very kind of you know ha ha
i know everything
and to a degree he was always kind of
that way he was always kind of like you
know if you can keep up with me then
it's just
you know thank god for small favors you
know it was always that kind of thing
but he was never really one of those
where he just seems
so disconnected from everything going on
right and that's really how he seems in
the mobius chair he just seems so
incredibly disconnected and he almost
kind of talks about the chair as if it's
a thing that he has to have
and he even refers to people as the
sense that like there's just a baseline
nature to all human beings that cannot
be altered based instincts there are
people out there that have a base
instinct kill
a base instinct to rob that kind of
thing it's almost batman to the small
degree that he did favor the possibility
of people being redeemed has even even
really just
lost that it's just kind of like people
do bad things and i'm just catching them
before they do it's a very cynical
perspective but here's the funny thing
about this
the way the batman handles a lot of
these situations are actually
awesome so here's one instance right
there's these guys who are going to be
heading to this place
called the alpha club and they're well
they intend they tend to rob the place
ultimately they got a whole bunch of
guns so you know most likely somebody
was going to get shot
but batman basically uses the mobius
chair and then teleports them to the
southern tip
of the arctic circle and is like you're
about 50 miles away from a research
station here
uh just be aware you are surrounded by
mountains not the biggest deal doesn't
usually get down to negative 40 but it
is currently negative two so
uh if you start burning the different
things in your car using the gunpowder
and your your bullets then you can
probably keep yourself warm there's a
ship that's on its way here
uh because it's just kind of making its
way through the ice they don't know
you're here but you know you guys will
stumble upon each other and maybe
they'll find a way to save you but uh
while you're while you're waiting on
them to arrive praying to god that you
actually live you can think about your
actions and just leaves
[Laughter]
just leaves he's just like bye and then
just you know okay bye bye and then just
just takes off and that's he just leaves
him there following that he goes to
another place where there's a guy named
mr phillips but he actually breaks into
his ex-wife's apartment with a knife in
hand
essentially drunk and the whole thing is
that he's pissed off because after
everything he had done
his wife had basically left him and
divorced him uh the reality is that he
was beating her
and so it's not as though she left him
because he was down on his luck because
he was running into some problems in the
job and she's like you're no measurement
at all you know and then just took off
to
to find greener pastures it's because he
was beaten on her right so batman ends
up snatching this
guy up and then takes him to themyscira
now initially the the
the women on themselves are just like
you're not supposed to be here you can't
just come here
whenever you want you can't just walk
into this place and they're like who who
is this guy
and he's like well this guy's name is mr
phillips and he likes to beat his women
and he intended to murder his ex-wife
with with the knife that he has in his
hand before i intervened uh
and so i have no intention of leading
him here but i felt like spending a
little while here will help change his
view on women and they're like yeah
yeah it will so you know the theme of
scares are going to help him come to
understand his place in the bigger
picture but that's kind of what happens
here now
batman in turn makes things personal
right he makes things very very personal
here and what he does is he goes to
crime alley and notice this being the
god of knowledge having all this this
knowledge at his fingertips knowing
everything that's going on across the
universe
batman could deal with all the
universe's problems instead he really
just kind of reduces down to dealing
with his own because he's exactly what
we've always said he was he's a sad
little boy crying because his mommy and
daddy got shot
now it doesn't make him any less of a
person because of that that's just
the core nature of batman their deaths
at the hands of joe chill and so what he
does is he actually
teleports directly to where joe chill's
at and gotham state penitentiary now
joe chill is not really serving a life
sentence he was serving his sentence but
he always keeps getting shot down by the
parole board so he is more or less
serving a life sentence and he always
will
because he essentially murder people who
are rich and powerful and as we know
it usually carries a heavier sentence
when you when you murder those
individuals who have money and are
influential and so the results of this
is that the the conversation bruce has
with
joe chill is one of wrath and vengeance
right and that's that's how we kind of
know
the mobius chairs corrupting him because
when you look at batman
whenever he's dealing with situations
like this especially when he's usually
dealing with criminals the element of
using
fear is only done insofar as to throw
them off guard
or to use it as a way to kind of terrify
them out of their actions or something
along those lines right it's designed to
be something that that
sort of messes with people's heads right
it's mind games shadow games that kind
of thing he never really uses fear for
the actual purpose
of just terrorizing a person right just
personal
vengeance he never really uses it for
that way but that's what he's doing with
joe chill
he's absolutely terrorizing this guy now
some could say and you really could
argue he's got a right to do this but
the crazy thing
is is that he actually teleports him
directly to uh to crime alley to the
point to the the place where the crime
was committed and joe chill almost kind
of gets excited about what was
going on he's like yeah man you know i
killed gotham's movies and shakers and
that's why i keep serving a life
sentence you know i
you know i i put a bullet in these two
super rich people
he's like in that moment i was the most
powerful i ever was i had the power of
life and death i decide who lives
and who dies you know and then he starts
talking about bruce wayne he's like you
know i bet that little kid he had
nightmares and everything you know he
was i was that little kid's boogeyman
right this whole idea that he felt like
god
right he felt like god insofar as he
could snuff out the lives of others or
determine or decide that they could live
and then became like this
specter that just haunted the life of
the eight-year-old boy who survived and
one of the things that he talks about
here is that when when batman
says like you know give me a number like
i know the waynes weren't the first ones
i know they weren't the only ones that
that you killed
give me a number he says 40 that he's
killed 40 people because of the fact
that it made him feel more empowered now
he did this
at the request of others he did it of
his own volition but regardless it
satisfied a personal desire
for him and that's the crazy thing is
because when bruce reduces it down and
says i'm not really here
for the 38 other people that you killed
i don't really care about them i care
about the two people you cured
killed here that night in crime alley
the response to joe chill is why like
why do you care about the two people
that i killed here in crime alley why
would batman be concerned about that and
that's when bruce reveals his identity
and says because i'm bruce wayne
right like and that immediately scares
the hell out of joe chill right
absolutely scares the heck out of him
because he's like i'm all grown up right
the first words that you have when you
when you come back to this place is
you wish you would kill the little kid
who was there so that nobody would have
been able to trace you to the crime and
you would have gotten away scot-free
that's the first thing you do but like
i'm your boogeyman now you have to
accept the fact that now you're the one
who created the batman i'm here because
of you i'm here because you killed my
parents and so i can make your life a
nightmare in this place joe chill i can
let word reach the ears of all the
prisoners around here who were here
because of batman that you're the reason
he exists if everybody here finds out
you're the one who created batman by
committing a murder in crime alley
they're all going to come for you they
can't get to me batman but they can get
to you
right so if they can't kill me they'll
do the next best thing and they'll make
your life a living hell in every
conceivable way and in some ways that
you can't even imagine
so i just want you to know right that's
that's literally the whole thing he
wants joe till to know the fact that joe
chill
created batman joe chill is the reason
that batman exists it's all about just
intimidation
and it's all it's all about just
terrorizing this guy and of course he
also goes on to say like you will never
tell anybody who i am you will never
give anybody my identity
if you will i will make sure that you
die in this place
and that's really what would happen like
batman if batman told people that joe
chill created batman they would kill joe
chill and so in a roundabout way maybe
not so many not in so many words
batman's like i will have you killed in
this place that's basically what he's
saying now of course once he gets back
directly to
uh to the the bat cave and you have
alfred there waiting on you know with
drinks and that kind of a thing and
dinner to kind of help him get together
batman start is basically bleeding from
the ears and the nose and the mouth
and the reason why is because the chair
is one of these things where
it doesn't necessarily have a mind of
its own but processing all that
information kind of creates a bond or a
link between the person
and the chair and so if you start using
the mobius chair for the
for means that it wasn't meant to be
used for personal gratification
different things like that
essentially defying the will of the
chair then it'll in turn cause problems
now the other thing this kind of hit out
here is that there almost seems to be a
parasitic relationship here in the sense
that if it was symbiotic
batman gains something the chair gains
something and then they both kind of go
forward but batman's struggling the way
that he is bleeding the way that he is
he goes as far as to say that he's
sustained by the chair right the chair
feeds it basically keeps him uh
nourished he doesn't have any need for
food or water or anything along those
lines that it does satisfy a need of the
chair in that way but it's taking a toll
on bruce wayne it's killing it in effect
right
because while bruce wayne may very well
be sustained the chair itself
almost seems to be sucking the life out
of him and that's that seems to be one
of the reasons why only new gods only
somebody like metron or a person like
that
who has who is by all standards of
measurement uh immortal in comparison to
whatever means of destruction are
available out there right he's not truly
indestructible he can be killed but it's
very very difficult to do but because
you have to have a kind of physiology to
be able to withstand the rigors of the
chair that it wasn't really meant for
mortal men and so because of that it's
taking the toll on batman
now alfred really kind of asked him like
why don't you just leave the chair
the sponsor bruce is well i can leave it
any time i want to notice this it's
almost like a drug or like an addiction
of some kind right bruce believes he has
to have the chair he needs the chair and
so there's almost kind of a mental link
in that way he talks like an addict well
i can quit anytime i want i can quit
drugs anytime i want i can stop drinking
any time i want i can quit gambling
anytime i want i got 10 to 1 odds i can
stop tomorrow you know it's that kind of
a thing but ultimately
he just doesn't acquiesce he just stays
on the chair now there almost seems to
be a kind of physical link in the sense
of batman
cannot actually get up the chair is
keeping in there but we don't really get
enough information to know whether or
not that's the case it just kind of
seems to me he tries to stand up and he
can't really do it almost as if
he he is attempting to get himself out
of the chair but doesn't actually want
to leave right maybe
you know not faking it or anything like
that but it's just a desire to stay in
the chair and to maintain all that
information
and so ultimately he says like me being
in this chair is really what's best for
gotham me having this at my disposal
this is the best thing for us because
now i can do a better job of one keeping
gotham under control
but two i can focus on the one thing
that has plagued me
ever since i became batman the one guy
that i've never been able to figure out
the person whose
entire existence is as much an enigma to
me as it is
seemingly everybody else his whole focal
point now that he has this knowledge
with regards to the mobius chair
is to figure out a way to understand who
the joker is
where he came from and what his whole
story is about now for those of you guys
who want to continue
off from where this whole idea about the
jokers continues we have the the story
the three jokers down in the description
you can watch that because that'll
actually pick up
immediately after this not directly and
you know it wasn't really written until
about five years
after this story was published but in
terms of chronology and in terms of
fitting into what's going on with batman
right now it fits in later but it
basically comes in so feel free to check
that out if you guys want to see what
happens next with the three joker story
and all that but that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you